alors frédéric ce débat autour du droit
à l'avortement il dure depuis des
décennies aux états unis mais tout a
changé en fait avec la décision de la
cour suprême russe wade
voilà exactement céline en fait avant
1973 l'avortement était légale seulement
dans quatre états américains
il était permis sous certaines
conditions dans ces états dans le reste
des etats-unis s'était complètement
interdit donc tout a commencé en fait en
1970 lorsque cette dame que l'on avait
nommé à l'époque janeiro parce qu'elle
voulait garder en fait son anonymat
c'est une texane du vrai nom de norma
mccorvey qui voulaient contester la loi
interdisant l'avortement au texas et en
disant que la loi finalement été trop
vague
en face d'elle elle a trouvé un monsieur
qui s'appelle henrie oued c'est en fait
l'un des procureurs du texas qui a
d'ailleurs gagné une première fois en
première instance dans ce combat trois
ans plus tard on a eu la décision finale
qui a été livré par la cour suprême de
l'époque le 22 janvier 1973 et qui a
légalisé l'avortement en se basant sur
le 14e amendement de la constitution
américaine qui devrait offrir la même
protection à tout le monde et donc sept
juges contre deux se sont prononcés en
faveur de cette légalisation mais il ya
eu plusieurs contestations déjà pour
essayer de renverser
oui c'est en fait c'est assez constant
il ya vraiment une seule contestation
majeure on va dire qui date de 1992 où à
l'époque c'était un combat entre pleine
période de doute donc cet organisme qui
fournit justement des services
d'encadrement pour les avortements
face à ce politicien démocrate pro-vie
baup qui s'y est à l'époque la cour
suprême des etats-unis a décidé en fait
de maintenir au contraire wade mais en
ouvrant quand même une certaine petite
porte notamment pour les états les états
qui ne peuvent toujours pas en fait
criminaliser l'avortement mais ça leur a
donné une fenêtre dans le sens où
maintenant on ne parle plus de
trimestres
on ne peut pas avorter après un certain
trimestre avec la décision 73 mais là
maintenant
depuis 92 on parle de viabilité du
foetus donc c'est le moment où le foetus
peut survivre en dehors de l'utérus et
du ventre de la mère donc ce qui fait
que dans le fond avant on parlait plus
de 28 semaines dans la décision de 73
mais depuis 92 en fait on a descendu
cette période à 23 24 semaines s'il veut
dire dans le fond que les états
on ne peut plus un grand champ d'action
pour intervenir et interdire
l'avortement à des gens qui voudraient
le demander et donc ce qui inquiète
beaucoup les pro choix dans le fond
c'est que on a déjà 350 projets de loi
qui ont été déposées en 2019 pour
essayer de restreindre l'accès
évidemment à l'avortement et ce qui
inquiète évidemment c'est la nouvelle
composition de la cour suprême très
conservatrice avec notamment monsieur
bret kavanagh donc point d'interrogation
qu'est ce qui va se passer dans les
prochains mois et les prochaines années
ça va être matière à débat toujours sur
l'avortement très divisés comme question
merci beaucoup à vous en prie